You're listening to radio lab from New York public radio, public radio,
w.
Y. Y. C. N. N. P. R.
I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich and this is Radiolab season three and let me start with a
story. Okay.
1893 an anthropologist friends Boaz goes to the woods of British Columbia.
He has a giant wax cylinder recorder with him and he records this guy
singing and healing. So,
uh,
and who? Who is this?
This gentleman is an Indian from the [inaudible] tribe and his name will told is
[inaudible]
what? At old castle. I was pronounced the castle at, I don't know,
I'm not quite sure how it would be pronounced.
Daniel Mormon. He's an anthropologist.
He's written a lot about Kessel because it's a neat story and it goes like this.
The young Caslit begins as a skeptic.
It was a skeptical about the activities of the shame and he thought they were
tricking people in some way. The Shaman or the village healers, very,
very powerful man. They were scary man.
He'd see them doing these dramatic healing rituals.
He thought they were full of it, and so he decided to go undercover one day.
Kessel approaches some of these shaman and asks if he can apprentice with them.
Yeah,
there's three or four of them taking them out into the woods and doors into a
clearing or something. I'm like, tell him a bunch of things,
or they taught him the songs
[inaudible]
he learned that stuff and eventually after he'd gained their trust a little,
they taught him their best trick of all a trick that's widespread in the world
of shamanism. Will you find variations on it all over the world?
Here's what you do. They told them, get some feathers, some down feathers,
and just tuck it in your tree quick, right?
Just stick it in your mouth secretly so that nobody knew that it was there.
Then during the ritual,
let's say the patient is there and they're on the ground.
Maybe their chest hurts. You lean down, literally get down.
If it's your mouth on the patient's chest and suck, and here's the last thing.
While you're sucking,
you bite the inside of your cheek to get some blood in there,
which mixes with the feathers. Then at the pivotal point,
you throw your head back in
car felt the feathers
which were now bloody and nasty,
so you ended up at this bit of bloody down in the palm of your hand,
which you would then say is the disease which you have sucked out of the body of
the patient.
Kessel had learned all this and thought I knew it, those,
the problem was that part of the obligation of his apprenticeship was that
whenever anybody asked, he had to go and treat them for free.
That was sort of part of the deal of being an apprentice and somebody from a
famous family called him to come and treat a daughter who was sick,
very sick according to the written account,
and so he went to see this family and he treated the girl and he went through
the songs that he sang.
Then he did the feather trick, which he knew was false.
Put the feathers in his mouth, get the inside of the tooth, pretended to set,
cough the whole thing out. And Lo and behold, she was healed. She was fine.
She was fine. She was, it was a great success. Wow. And what did he think? Well,
he, he,
he clearly indicates a kind of ambiguity.
He knows that he was tricking her, but he also knows that she's better
not convinced. Kessel had tries to trick again and again and again.
And every time he does it, it works. So at the end of the story,
he decides to become a healer.
Does that mean that he ends up believing in the lie that he set out to disprove?
I think that he realizes that truth and lies are not that fundamentally
different as we might think they are
today on radio lab. We look at that,
the true healing power of lies, which she,
in medicine we call the placebo effect. No, no, we don't. What do you mean? No,
we don't? Well, it's actually called Plug Chabo pla cable. Who calls it that?
It was Latin scholars. I think it's a Latin word. [inaudible] lack word.
Why you call it the placebo effect.
I'm going to try and figure it out how it works,
and then I'm going to tell some stories,
including one about a dramatically dressed gentleman.
He dressed entirely in purple and maybe it was lacked who used a placebo effect
to make the ladies feel real good.
That's all coming up on radio lab.
[inaudible]
Steve [inaudible] documented [inaudible] eh? Yes. Speak [inaudible].
I am somebody [inaudible] I cannot hear anything.
We had a little trouble with the phone connection for Reseal Benedetti as a
doctor at the Turin Medical Center in Italy and he's one of the most expert
experts on the placebo effect. Better? Yeah. Now I can hear you. Yes.
So we thought we'd start with him.
He's been studying the placebo effect for about 15 years. Yeah,
I got too interested in the placebo effect because, uh,
I realize that that sometimes the placebo group gets much better than,
uh, the active treatment group.
Much, much better.
Yeah. Sometimes. Sometimes.
For what kind of stuff? Well, he saw it first in pain, pain,
pain trials. Oh. And then he saw it in depression, oppression,
and then antidepressants. Right. And then digestions Jen immune response. Yes.
All of these places where placebos were doing things they just were not supposed
to do.
Yeah. It's really amazing. Particularly for some conditions like [inaudible].
This one's a little surprising
Parkinson's disease,
since there's the serious [inaudible] neurological disorder,
people with Parkinson's have shakes, they have tremors.
Dr Benedetti treats a lot of these folks, and in the really bad cases,
the only treatment that really seems to work at all is surgery.
So these patients,
you open up the patient's skull and implant a little stimulator deep into their
brain,
deep into the brain in two brain regions.
Essentially what that does is it hot wires,
the parts of the brain that aren't working. And when you do that,
you turn the stimulator on, the shakes go away. It's a real treatment. Yes.
So we can switch the stimulator on or off and the patient doesn't know that the
stimulator is on or off.
And that is where the trickery comes in. And one experiment,
he stood in front of his patient with the stimulator and said,
now we are going to switch your stimulator on.
Except he didn't [inaudible].
No, of course. Of course. It is a sham turning.
He only pretended to turn it on, but that's the weird thing. It didn't matter.
Pretending to turn it on work just as well as turning it on for real.
The tremors disappeared. Really?
He even has a video of this where he's with a Parkinson's patient and he says
those words,
no, we are going to switch your stimulator on,
which is a lie by the way. Yeah,
but it doesn't matter because what you see on the video screen is a shaking hand
go completely [inaudible].
Yeah, that's correct. In a few seconds,
you see that the Riza dramatic improvement in motor performance,
even though the, the stimulator is still off,
just from words, and this is an equivalency. The lie is as good as the medicine
[inaudible]
for awhile. What do you mean for a while coming out of the gate,
a placebo seems to be 100% as effective as say, a real Parkinson struggle.
Yeah. Gotcha.
The plastic only about 25% the duration of the actual drug.
Ah, still it's just words. Words are cheap. Yeah. You want it cheaper than,
Oh yeah,
overstatement.
25% that is so different from 100% never said it was 100% to,
I didn't roll the tape back. What's wrong with you?
The fact that it happens at all. That words, that's all we're talking about.
Words can be as effective as surgery. Doesn't that one,
doesn't that intrigue you that you want to know how that works? Yes,
actually I do.
How does it work? We have no idea,
but for the first time we can see it.
See what we'll see it in action. See the placebo effect in action. Oh, testing.
Testing. Dr Benedetti referred us to a guy. Actually right here
in your yard. Probably. You have a token with the Tar Wagga? No.
Should we? Yes, totally. Go. Are you [inaudible]? Yeah. Hey, how are you? Oh,
to work. I use a really good new imager. We should introduce yourself. Okay.
I'm Troy [inaudible].
I'm an assistant professor of Psychology at Columbia University.
And here's what tour wigger does. He puts subjects in the brain scanner. Yeah.
Puts a hot pad on their arm like I'm doing to you right now. So that's very,
yeah, right, right. We'll give them these pulses of heat
and then he'll give you some pain relief cream.
This creamier cream that we tell you is [inaudible].
We say this is going to be really effective. This is going to block pain,
take away the
pain. Really. It's just fascinating, but you know,
know that I'm having a hard time playing this role. Many games,
right as you're putting on this fake cream and feeling better,
having a placebo effect. In other words, he takes [inaudible]
picture of your brain. So I have many things I can show you.
Come on until I show it to him. He does. He shows me going on his computer.
It's very pretty. Now we had a brain in front of us,
the brain scan of a person right in the middle of being placebo,
meaning that they've just been given the placebo cream and now they're expecting
to feel better. Those expectations, placebo expectations, first of all,
they seem to start here in your forehead, kind of on the sides of your forehead.
Above your temples. When you believe that you're going to feel better.
That belief seems to live kind of near your temples,
but then once that belief is there, it seems to turn on. Turn on this,
this other part, the midbrain, he points to it on the screen.
It's a little nugget deep in the center of the brain.
What's important about this area is that it's one of the major centers for the
production of opioids in the brain. Oh, opioids like opium. Yes.
Yeah. Right. Like opium.
Opium as in
[inaudible].
Jad the greatest painkiller known to man there.
It was inside our heads in a strike.
By the way, that that stuff actually is inside our heads.
I can't get over that [inaudible] that these illicit substances are actually
inside us. Right? We know there's kind of a neat story about that,
and here is where tor blows my mind right out my face as he explains it.
Every drug out there in the world, every single one,
even the ones you see on TV or in a sense already inside our heads,
your brain must have its own internal chemicals.
The only reason those drugs work he says is because our brain has receptors for
them. And why would it have those receptors?
Because it can already make them in house every pharmacological agent or drug
that there is. You know,
there is a chemical that's produced by your own brain that essentially does that
thing.
It's like an internal pharmacy in there and it's just stocked full of drugs.
Right. And we just have to figure how to unlock it.
We have a sort of a, as you said, we can turn our pharmacy,
but we don't know why. Sometimes you does not work.
What? What does that mean? Well, what it means is that the placebo effect,
though it can be incredibly powerful. It's rarely consistent.
It's hard to predict who's going to get a placebo effect under what
circumstances.
But just imagine if we could figure this out and we can have all the drugs we
ever need without those nasty side effects.
Oh yes, absolutely. Yes.
We are working a lot with a drug companies in this direction
with Dr Benedetti he's looking at now,
which could be huge for patients with chronic pain.
It toxic drug like morphine. Hmm.
Gradually replace it with a placebo substitute.
So say on Monday he would give you some morphine and then on Tuesday slip in a
placebo
and you'd give motion to gay on Wednesday and the placebo on Thursday and so
forth. In the longer run that you can have a reduction of morphine by 50%
Aha. And perhaps one day, I'm sorry, I can't contain my enthusiasm.
We won't need drugs at all.
Maybe one day we'll have a little box that I can plug directly into my midbrain
and I can just spend all day hitting the joy button. Joy, joy,
joy,
[inaudible].
Sorry about that. Well,
while we're waiting for your glorious drug soaked future,
you could do it much more simply by simply telling a story.
I'll tell you a story about telling stories. How about that?
I have no idea what you're talking about, right? Well, let me start.
It's a story I learned from Daniel Carr. Daniel B. Carr, m d a.
He told me about a guy who's really the father of placebo research.
His name is Henry Henry [inaudible]. Annexed,
annexed is his original name, German.
As Dr Carl will tell you which given the poor quality of my German,
I would roughly scan as meaning anti anxiety or perhaps anti pain.
This may be one of those cases with the name shapes the man.
It may well be,
it may well be cause even though he ends up changing his name to be sure Henry
knows Beecher, he does go into medicine to become a doctor.
And then during World War II he joined the army as a doctor and found himself
the great battle of Anzio and the Americans landed in Nazi Europe and he was
right there. He was
beach. Well let's go. Flying.
Soldiers were being killed and some were being wounded
and since Beecher was the doctor, it was his job to treat them. That's correct.
The treatment at that time for pain as it still is nowadays was morphine.
One problem though,
Beecher's division was cut off from supplies and reinforcements and he began to
run low on morphine.
He had to figure out which soldiers needed it the most and he's,
he's talking to them and he's asking him that.
How much pain they're actually having. This is Scott Podolsky,
he's a doctor and his star. And he would go up to these patients and say them.
So soldier, yes, as you lie there, as you lie there, are you having any,
you having any pain quote unquote. So imagine Jed, you're a soldier,
you're lying there with shrapnels stuck in your guns or severe injuries and you
haven't had any morphine for at least seven hours previously. Yeah. Seven hours.
So what would you say? Oh would, I said, well, um, I'd say,
give me some more feed. I'm in pain. Do you want to know something?
The striking finding was that in 75% of them they'd say, no, no,
no doc, I'm okay. I don't need any morphine right now.
Three quarters of them said that, wow,
this didn't make a whole lot of sense to be true because knew about pain before
the war. He ran a clinic in Boston,
so he would see people with bullet injuries and gun injuries,
more or less the same kind of injuries he saw on the battlefield.
But back in Boston, doc, they really hurt. Did I have anyone?
Morphine please. Nurse. For some strange reasons. As Daniel Carr,
the intensity of the pain associated with being shot was lower in the
battlefield than in civilian life. What could explain that? Yeah.
Maybe soldiers are just, they're tough guys. They don't. They suck it up.
They don't. Well, no, no context context. That was beaches.
Very simple explanation, context, context,
meaning that the pain that you feel when you're hit by a bullet,
it's not just about the bullet,
it's just as much about the story that comes with the bullet.
So consider these two different stories. Story number one,
you are a soldier than you've been shot.
As the bullet passes through. The first thing you think is, Oh man,
I'm shot. The second thing you think is, wait a second, I'm alive.
If I can be evacuated from here, I'll have a period of recuperation.
They'll take me to a hospital, there'll be nurses there.
I may get a metal and a pension or a bonus and they'll certainly be a though,
send me home, throw me a parade.
I'll be a hero.
Now consider the civilian story this time. You're a regular guy,
civilian in Boston. Maybe you own a shop. Can I help you pick up,
give me your money and you've been shot as the bullet passes to you this time,
the thoughts flashing to your head have nothing to do with the glory.
That's right. Instead you think, yeah, I'm alive,
but what's going to happen to me now? You wouldn't get a metal. Uh,
you were in trouble. Am I going to pay the doctor bills?
Going to be out of commission but to lose my job? How do I pay the rent?
And if your family was dependent upon you, they suffered.
Nothing good is going to come up. This one bullet,
two very different stories. And it's the difference in the stories.
So Dr Beecher, that explains the difference in the experience of pain.
Those stories you're saying are somehow filtering the pain even before it's
felt. Yeah. That even as the bullet enters the skin right away,
within seconds thereafter,
you spin yourself a story about what's going to happen to you next.
Not Consciously,
but way down deep in your head and the story you tell that makes all the
difference.
Scientists currently view our whole identity as something that we construct one
fraction of a second to another.
You are the unfolding of an ongoing narrative,
but it's not just a narrative in words. It's a narrative that involves touch,
color, odors.
We use all those inputs to generate the next frame from the last four
[inaudible]
true. Let me talk for a second about color. He just mentioned color, right?
Daniel Mormon. Yeah. Okay.
Tell me something really interesting about color and pill.
Cool colored pills,
blue pills or purple pills as placebos make better sleeping tablets than yellow
or red pills, which tend to wake people up. That's been, that's been shown. Oh,
yeah, yeah, yeah. There's that. Okay. Take two pills that are the same.
It says color one blue [inaudible] the other red and the people that take the
blue pill will sleep longer and they will sleep better than people who took the
red. This has been shown, he says all over the world except,
and here's the cool part. Yeah. Except in Italy, Italy. Hemp in Italy,
blues sleeping tablets have the paradoxical effect of being sleep inducing for
women but not for men. What, how does that work? Well, I'm not really sure,
but uh,
but my speculation is that the Italian national football team is called
[inaudible], which is blue.
And so what blew evokes in an Italian man is the World Cup and soccer and
screaming and hollering again
[inaudible]
and it's hardly something that's like
I guess by contrast, Hulu for Italian women is the color of the virgin.
The original does of course always presented in blue
[inaudible]
and the virgin is a very comforting and protective figure for women in Italian
culture.
[inaudible]
language and meaning are, are the most crucial dimensions of our wise
this is Radiolab.
I'm Jad up and Rod Robert Krulwich and I will continue in a moment.
This is Jennifer
for from Tampa.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public understanding of science and
technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hi,
it's Rachel Martin from NPR news up first is the morning news podcast from NPR.
When news moves fast,
it's the quick morning update on what happened and what you need to start your
day. The most important news in about 10 minutes or so,
wake up with up first every day.
You can find it by 6:00 AM eastern time on the NPR one app or wherever you
listen to your podcasts.
This is Radiolab.
I'm Jad Homerun and I'm Robert Krulwich and this hour we've been talking about
the placebo effect. Yes,
about the power of belief and suggestion and thus far we've looked at it from
the perspective of the patient,
but certainly the doctor has a role to play in all of this and so I have a story
to tell you. Five four, three two one zero it's,
it happens to be a better doctor. Yeah. I'm Dr. Mason.
I was trained in medicine in guy's hospital back in the 1950s Albert Mason was
delivering babies at a hospital in London.
He was a young guy at anesthesiologist and he was looking for a new way to
anesthetize his patients, the moms southern, maybe safer than drugs.
And one day he ran across a book about mythical hypnosis,
medical hypnosis.
And I just read the technique and tried it out on some friends.
And under what circumstances, like you,
you would put a watch and have it swing back and forth left and right. No, no,
no.
Just lay them down on a couch and say I'm now I want you to let your whole body
go loose at your arms, go loose as your legs go loose.
And it worked on some people and not on others, but the more he practiced,
the better he got. You know, putting his friends on tour trans stay,
getting them to remember stuff from their fifth birthday and all sorts of games
that we played as medical students.
And so we took this little party trick into the delivery room and it worked.
That's right. I delivered about 20 babies under hypnosis.
And the moment you start to do hypnosis,
you start to get a reputation as being somebody who has power. Well,
I would think you'd get two reputations.
The patients might think you have power and the doctors might think you're a
quack. Well, both of those are true,
but at that time it was kind of fun because the hospital administrators were
kind of curious about this young doctor. Slash. Hypnotist.
Maybe he was onto something, who knows?
So they started to send him all kinds of patients, skin disorders,
asthma, and he'd hypnotized them,
which led to a weird little discovery of all things that hypnosis might help.
The one that seemed to work the best was warts, warts,
warts. To my delight,
I found that if you hypnotize them and told them that the waltz would go,
they went in a certain number of cases. Let's fast forward a little bit.
Dr. Mason is treating lots of these warts patients and things are going pretty
well and one day a young boy came to this hospital.
He was wheeled in on a Gurney and the first thing I saw was his arm.
I could have dropped through the floor because this wasn't a dozen walls.
This was millions. This was the entire surface of the skin.
It's cracked and got infected and his life was impossible.
He couldn't go to school because he smelled a,
I don't know if you've ever seen the photographs of this boy.
Just check this out. Look at this pictures here. Oh my God.
It looks like he has a, a black hide over his whole body.
It looked like an elephant skin. That's what it looked like.
So they take this poor boy to surgery. The surgeon, a man called Jerry Moore,
was trying to graft healthiest skin onto the hands.
And when I saw this skin, I said to Mr. Moore,
why don't you treat him by hypnosis? And he looked at me and he said, well,
why don't you, and he walked out with here.
Why don't you in, in despair or in contempt?
I think a mixture of both. And by the way, when you asked that question,
you're the kid asking the senior practitioners. So I was cheeky.
Yeah, you were cheeky. So there's Albert Mason,
cheeky Aloma is boy with a million warts and Albert asks him,
do you mind if I hit my Tyson? This kid who was 15 said, okay,
didn't you have to tell the parents? Um, no.
Couldn't have got away with it today, could I?
[inaudible]
so I hypnotized this kid.
I told him the watch on your right arm will shrivel up and die and new skin will
grow. And why did you choose the right arm? Oh,
I had to start somewhere and I sent him away.
He came back in a week and one arm was clear.
Aw,
totally clear. I mean, imagine this,
the left arm is black and scaly like elephant skin and the right arm is totally
normal. Totally normal looking yet. But here's the rub on look,
this no's a real photo. This is a, this is verifiable.
It looked like a normal skin, but rather pinker than usual.
Slightly pink and soft and supple.
Oh,
this is for real? Yes.
It's like all those thousands and thousands of words that covered the right arm.
I guess they just fell over. And what were you thinking when you first saw it?
I was thinking how wonderful.
I was thinking, oh wait, let Mr. Moore sees this.
So he takes the boy, he runs down the hall to the operating room.
When Mr. Mueller is in the middle of an operation,
he takes the boy up to the big, you know, the glass window,
and I held up both his arms, one black and Scaly,
the other pink and and more put down his scalpel.
He came out of the theater and he looked and he said, oh my God,
look at that. And I sure will. I told you a waltz could go.
And he looked at me pityingly he said, this isn't what this is congenital
[inaudible] [inaudible] of bro went off. For those of us who are uninitiated,
what is Roma? Damien with witty guy, bad guy with Axios, hopeless condition.
Never been known to,
to change this surgeon informed Albert Mason that he had just hypnotized away a
condition that never once in medical history had been known to go away for any
reason, whatever. So he says,
we're going to take him to the Royal Society of medicine to show him to all the
dermatologists in London.
[inaudible]
so more took me up there with the boy.
Thank you Dr Molan to the Royal Society for this opportunity.
And I demonstrated, yes. First of all, I demonstrated how to hypnotize.
This is quite easily achieved. You simply lie the patient down and say,
now I want you to let your whole body go loose. Let your arms go loose,
let your legs go loose. And then I showed his arm, please, if you don't mind,
raise both arms.
They were staggered. In fact, the president,
this is upset that it's
inconceivable that this gets well because we all knew that congenital
[inaudible] is incurable
[inaudible].
That was the exact word he used in curable, incurable,
no
curable. And the thing was, since all this took place at a hospital,
every stage of it was documented.
There are photographs every step along the way before shots after shots,
closeups, all available to reporters. You can imagine what happened, right?
It was picked up in every newspaper, Time magazine, big media story. In fact,
the first I heard about it, I was in bed one morning,
a year after I'd sent the paper in from habilitation,
and the phone rang and the voice said, this is whipsnade zoo.
We have an elephant with a skin like a little boy, can you kill him? And I said,
what's up? I don't know what the hell are you talking about?
And then the phone started to ring and ring and ring and hundreds of calls,
hundreds of letters came in from all over the world.
And I had people coming in with the most terrifying illnesses wanting to be
killed, especially people with that very rare skin condition,
congenital [inaudible], whatever it's called. Yes.
They flocked to him from all over the world.
And that's now here's where the story takes a turn. He would see these patients,
he would hypnotize each one one at a time and then send them away,
hoping of course that they'd get better. Right.
And they would come back a week later.
And
none of the others ever got well
at all. No,
not in any way. No improvement. Um,
I've spent the rest of my life trying to understand this phenomenon because I
gave up and it's just a few years later,
Albert Mason quit medicine and he decided to become a psychiatrist.
He wanted to understand why he had the touch the first time and why after that
it just didn't work.
So the central question in your mind was not what happened to the kid,
but what happened to me. That's right. That's right.
And what do you think the answer to that is? Like? Well,
there is a condition called infantile omnipotence that we all suffer from when
we're kids.
We think we can do anything unconsciously.
I knew this was incurable. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
My reason cause it incurable would mean that it had never been cured.
But you've tried. You had tried, created an exception. So look,
when you're 20 and the president of the Royal Society of medicine tells you it's
incurable, it has an effect. That's his best guess.
He thinks that that word incurable
changed him just a little bit.
I lost my crazy confidence even though I had the evidence,
but it didn't work.
No.
Confidence is a hard thing to measure. You can't put it on a scale.
You can't weigh it,
but you can sense it because it's conveyed in a million little ways how you
stand, whether you look your patient in the eye, when you pause,
where you pause, what you say, what you don't say.
All these things are like signals may say to the patient,
they murmur to the patient. I can help you. They can do this. You know,
you go to a doctor, you got this horrible rash all over you and he says,
um Oh that's everything my multiform me and you feel better immediately cause
he's named it will.
All he said is many red spots in Latin.
But the thing is that he knows what it is and you feel that,
oh he knows now I'll be okay
because when you're feeling terrible,
what you just want to do is hand over the authority for your situation to
someone else who's got information. Yeah,
hour and he's going to tell you you're going to be fine.
And maybe that comes out from early childhood when it seems to us that our
parents have that capacity. Harvard historian and Harrington,
I have a two year old and we're already now at the stage where, you know,
he gets a little bump and he comes to me and holds the bit of his body out
that's been hurt and I kiss it and it's OK and I,
there is a way that mommy's kiss is kind of a placebo effect. Testing,
testing and now imagine that are sick.
You know when you're sick there's a strong impulse to kind of revert back to
that way of interacting with people.
Say something just a duck that's Arabic for what do you want?
How's that? How are you? I'm good dad. How are you? I'm doing very well.
This is my dad. Do you see how your voice goes on the thing? He's the guy.
I bring my booboos too as a kid. Tell me what you do.
Actually I still do like your title and that kind of thing cause he happens to
be a doctor. I'm the chairman of the Barclay of surgery at Vanderbilt.
Vanderbilt is in Nashville, Tennessee where we grew up for much of our life.
Where are you? Grew up for much of your life. Okay,
so my dad had no idea why I wanted to follow him around the hospital.
I didn't exactly lead with the whole placebo thing. Often do see patients.
Truth is, I feel okay about that because this show isn't really about lying.
It's about healing the healing process, which doesn't happen in a vacuum.
Patient of course has to believe in the cure,
but the doctor has to create that book. Okay, wait, you have to walk slower.
I can't talk slowly now. How does he do that? Tell me where we're going.
Now we're going into the clinic and it'd be more specific with what happens at
the clinic. If I have patients scheduled to come to see me today.
These days my dad's hair is white, is his white Dr Kobish,
but he still sees patients every Wednesday.
I have four patients and that is why I'm here.
1:00 PM clinic begins in the clinic and as if to illustrate an Harrington's
basic point, when you're sick,
there's a strong impulse to kind of revert back to that way of interacting with
people.
As soon as my dad's first patient shows up a hairstylist from Murfreesboro,
Tennessee, when she walked down the busy hallway and sees him.
As soon as she sees him, she bursts into tears.
Okay, okay. So
he gives her a hug. Every time I see him,
it's kind of like a whole app,
have to be strong and I feel like when I see him I can let him let it down
because I know that he's going to hug me and make me feel better.
I'm a single parent and I own my own business and I,
I've always been in survival mode and I've always had to be strong and so that's
why this has been so hard for me.
They go into a tiny exam room,
which is quiet and super intimate compared to the hallway.
Dad Has Megan sit on a table if stuff,
and he gently presses two fingers to her next swallow a little bit [inaudible]
there's a tiny gland in her neck that should be the size of a Ph [inaudible] but
over the past four years it's gotten bigger.
Three inches and bigger word and two and a half inches in the other direction.
Now it's the size of a golf ball and it presses against your area.
Yeah. At night sometimes I wake up and I'm, you know, and I think, Oh God,
should I call nine one one and I keep asking him every week,
are you sure I'm not going to choke? I got a choke kiss. Not going to choke me.
Or You know, just him reassuring me it's not gonna affect the airway.
I tried to remember the little things that he says to me when I'm,
especially in the middle of the night when I start feeling anxious or panic at
all. Same time. How do I deal with the anxiety surrounding this thing?
Because like
anxious feelings of anxiety that I don't know.
We're going to scared of the unknown part that is worrying about the future.
I think just because I think, well I know,
but I guess it's just because of my race, my personal responsibilities.
You got to put them at ease.
Nothing life threatening today you have to put them at ease.
I'm going to give you a short term plan and a longer term medicine where just
science and all of this talk would be just noise because the real business
within happen in the next room where this big machine ready to scan Megan's
thyroid, but medicine isn't purely science. Yeah. I mean, which my dad had met.
It's an art. It's communication,
which is why he and Megan talk and talk and talk and talk for over an hour.
In a way it's a kind of negotiation.
She wants to know one thing like what if my thyroid has gotten bigger?
What if I have to have radiation, will I have to quit my job?
He needs her to focus on anything but the what ifs to stay focused on what they
do know,
which unfortunately is that they won't know anything for another day.
Then you draw the blood today and believe it or not,
I know it's within 24 hours. Okay.
I need to know the size of that title.
Okay. Somehow in the end, despite all the open questions on this,
because as they do that, he gets there to relax. We're gonna work together.
We're going let you guys talk on the town so much.
It's really inconvenient for me. How much performances in it?
What do you mean performance? Yeah.
How much of doctoring is having to play a certain role that the patient needs at
that moment? It's just about every bit of it.
So if I were to call it theater, would that offend you or no,
it's not a theater that uh, it is,
I'm living that throat. It's part of me.
It's not part of a fake image that I'm projecting.
I think you know what I'm trying to get at, you know, you know,
you call it theater, you can call it theater, but I just mean that.
I mean when you, when you don't have the white coat on you,
you're not like in doctor mode. You know, you don't have all the answers.
You don't, I mean, I don't have all the answers then like, but you,
but you seem to, and you know, with her, that's what I really wanted to know.
That magic pixie dust called certainty.
How do you project that instantly to patient? The moment you walk into a room,
even when the patient hits you with questions like doc, am I going to make it?
It can seem kind of mystical, that aura,
but then again there are the props. Okay.
You have to tell me what you're doing now.
What does this for instance to rewind a moment here we are before clinic in my
dad's office and he's just opened up his little coat closet. I think my coat on,
I've got my, usually on the day of the clinic I choose a clean white coat.
Really? Yeah. Do you have many to choose from?
I have one, two, three, four, five, five,
five blindingly white light coats.
He flips through them because the whitest of the bunch puts it on and I swear to
you, even now when I'm older, it's supposedly wise to these kinds of things.
It's like he changes somehow.
Do you ever go to see patients without your weight?
Uh, I don't like to it. Yeah. It's almost like you're naked without it.
You do seem tolerant with it on, can I do? Yeah.
There is inherent power in the props, especially the code.
And if you have any doubt the doctors don't know this, go to a med school,
any med school on the day the new students arrive and you'll probably find
something like this. Excuse me. If we could all have a seed,
we'll start ceremony.
The white coat ceremony. Thank you.
It's as close to religious ritual as you can get in medicine. In fact,
the one that we attended at Columbia University in New York,
I asked the students to please stand with me included a chaplain.
Hmm.
As you are able let us pray together.
Compassionate God.
Okay.
Bless these new medical students of the Columbia University College of
Physicians and surgeons and bless the white coats that they receive today.
May these white coats be for each student,
a cloak of compassion, a clear statement of purpose,
a sign of assurance and a symbol of respect.
The ceremony we pray for the straight and fucking times has some on the
spiritual component, the art of healing. It's quite moving, I think.
I hope you'll find that's Arnold and Sandra gold.
They began the white coat ceremony at Columbia almost 20 years ago.
God be with each student and they were in the audience today. We were there,
God be with each of us along with about 250 students and their families first.
Each student is cloaked individually and Cole by name,
Eric, j. R e s James J at Tra.
They then return to the seats that we see,
this visual transformation that occurs.
This is a change that you can actually see at these people come into this room
with their coats on their arm and they're wearing blue and black and green and
yellow, and that's who they are, God.
And you see the room filling up in white and they see the room filling up in
white Alexandra j Borst. And you know in the old days, doctors were black.
It's true. A hundred years ago, doctors were gothic black coats,
but then someone discovered germs and have the insight that germs live in dirt.
And because you couldn't see dirt on black coats had to be white.
They changed for antiseptic reasons.
That is when a certain symbolism took hold. When you think about angels,
they're never in red. They're never in black.
Please turn around to face the audience
and I present to you the class of 2000
[inaudible]
radio. Lamb will continue in a moment. Hi,
I'm Miley Dunkin from Brooklyn, New York.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
bye.
This is Annie Schrader calling from Salmon, Idaho.
Radiolab is supported by Casper and award-winning manufacturer of one premium
mattress.
It's engineered for supportive comfort and ships in a compact box right to your
door with free shipping and returns was supportive.
Memory Foam Casper creates a sleep surface that contours to your body.
Casper gives you quality mattresses at a great price.
You can order online and try it in your own home risk-free for 100 nights.
Save $50 on your Casper mattress by visiting casper.com/radio lab and using the
offer code Radiolab.
This is Radiolab.
I'm Jad up and running and I'm Robert Krulwich and today we are talking about
the placebo effect and the power of suggestion.
We're looking at a lot of new research. Well, I don't know. It was new research.
We've, we've done well. It is a new research,
but the problem has been with us for centuries,
even at the very beginning of the age of reason. Let me take you back.
18th Century. The enlightenment was in full swing. There was change in the air.
Both hair was denouncing the church by Belize. Man.
Ben Franklin was flying kites
live was Yang, was inventing chemistry.
It was the beginning of modern times. Modern Science, you might say,
reason in creep. People were reexamining the big questions.
How does the world work? What possibly could hold everything together?
And this was new. Well,
you have to understand that in earlier historical moments,
the unification of the universe was not a problem because it was God that
unified everything and everything was a manifestation of God.
That's Ed Cohen talking about God, he's a historian.
But if God isn't the glue that holds the universe together,
then what does hold the world together? Enter End Twan. Mesmer and who?
N Twan. Ms Maria. Have you ever said, uh, you mesmerize me, my darling.
Go to that said the word Mesmer.
I'm as mesmerization comes from Anton Mesmer.
So he's part of our narrative. Yeah,
I'll get out of my way over to the other side of the story.
Out in 1778 he moves to Paris and he has a theory.
He believed that the world was filled with a kind of fluid that moved to all
living things and he gave it his own kind of sexy name, animal magnetism,
or as they say in the fringe, magnetism. [inaudible]. Right.
And as this force flowed through all of life,
occasionally it would get stuck in a traffic jam. It would bunch up. Right.
And that is also the bunching up can also be a cause of a problem.
That's what he thought.
Being sick was blocking the flow restrictions and the flow of animal magnetism
in the organism. I mean,
not that dissimilar to the way that we understand traditional Chinese medicine
or like ci with the needles and the and the acupuncture.
Mesmer thought this life was when it got stuck,
could be released with a little help from needles. No, no. This is a breakfast.
A lot more theatrical. He created a kind of [inaudible].
I actually think of it as um, a prototype for the,
the idea of a happening in the 60s that's the way I like to think of it.
You know,
it's sort of like everybody kind of came in and there was this like music
playing,
there was like dim lighting and he would walk around in his lovely purple suit
and, and he had a lit her pole. Yeah, I think he was a, a Laila
was, I believe actually the,
the shade that was reported and then he would go over to a particular client.
Usually it was a women,
most of his clients were women and he would sit across from them and their knees
would tuck yo magnet.
[inaudible] it is, how do you say,
pushy and then to unblock this flow,
he would stare into her eyes stare. Right.
And if he, if he jammed you, how would you know? Okay,
cause you would have a healing crisis. What was that? A simple,
they would scream, they would vibrate
actually a padded room where the ladies could go and loosen their corsets and
fling themselves about and banging their heads against the wall and do whatever
they needed to do in order to kind of release the damned up energy.
Well, it was apparently quite dramatic
by the looks of it.
They were real seizures and people said they felt better afterwards.
So word spread and Sunni had disciples and then more disciples.
It had a lot of popularity. Yes, it did.
So we did what any business man would do. He franchised it, he branched out.
And I mean this, literally, he magnetized trees, trees,
trees, Mesmer,
or sometimes his assistants would take to magnetised iron rods,
touch them to a tree in the forest,
and that would transfer the magnetism to the tree.
The tree would then have the kind of therapeutic powers that a mesmerist would
have. How convenient. That's in Harrington, a Harvard historian.
And this was quite efficient because then you could sort of have the trees do
part of the work for you.
So imagine if you will.
Lots and lots of people gathered around the tree touching each other and the
tree and allowing the flow to move through them and they would all have fits
together.
And the problem was the doctors of the time who used to have all these people as
their patients were now losing patients and money.
So they protested to the king. The king established a commission.
And actually one of the members of that commission was Benjamin Franklin,
who at the time was the ambassador to France.
And there were other important scientists on the [inaudible]
[inaudible] teen was one of them. Is that the g team? We know from the right.
So we're talking here about a major, major league panel. These were big guys,
big names,
and they devised a series of experiments to test for magnetic field.
They weren't concerned whether or not animal magnetism work.
They were concerned whether or not animal magnetism
existed because they figured, you know, it couldn't work.
[inaudible]
even though it may not exist.
And one of the most dramatic, uh,
tests that they devised is sometimes identified as the first placebo controlled
trial in history.
[inaudible].
They were actually down on Benjamin Franklin's estate.
This was just south of Paris and Franklin himself conducted experiment and it
involved blindfolding kind of a young boy. Is it on too tightly? No. Yeah,
that was what? 1213 years old. Can you see anything? No. Any light at all?
No. And uh, he was told that is the deal, young boy,
a lot of these five oak trees,
one of the trees on the estate has been advertised by an actual mesmerist.
Oh, we'll take him to one tree at a time.
Your job is to tell us which one has been magnetized and they said one of the
tree has been magnetized. And where you blindfold you and you,
you tell us when you know you're up by the magnetic trees.
Cause patients insisted that they could feel the energy. And by the way,
I believe that
I'm totally persuaded that the real experiences were happening.
They brought the boy to one tree. This is tree number one. Huh?
He began to kind of shake and they brought him to another. Nah,
we started before tree number two. He began to sweat.
And by the time they brought him to the third and then the forward.
Yeah, we are all before tree number.
He sort of collapsing convulsions, which is all dramatic except okay.
Tree number one, tree number two and number three and number four. Yup.
Had never been magnetized. So
this was seen as pretty definitive evidence that there was no man magnetic force
here. But they also didn't think that the boy was sort of faking it.
So what they concluded was that there is no magnetic force,
but that all the effects which they don't deny the reality of were caused by the
imagination.
That was Harvard historian and Harrington and Rutgers historian Ed Cohen.
I final stuff in this hour comes from reporter Gregory Warner who recently
visited a tent revival, upstate New York, little Adirondacks,
lakeside community, very rural to see a faith healing. Okay. So,
so I get there and I'm a little bit late. I'm a little bit nervous.
There's a lot of mosquitoes. People are restless.
They're sitting in their chairs, the tent flaps are still up,
the sun is kind of setting. And Steve,
Steve Booza is going on about some verses of scripture and people are really
bored. And he says, don't worry, we're going to get to the healing. Pretty soon.
The reading's important to, you know, that kind of thing like a teacher. Like,
so then he says, okay, now it's time for some healing.
The flaps go down and suddenly the changes because
what was before this kind of people milling in and out becomes this very focused
chamber and it begins your Neat Ministry of any kind.
Come on up. This preacher who, who is this guy? That's Steve Booza,
he owns a construction company in Syracuse. All the need
physical healing finances.
So he's looking out into the crowd and then a volunteer comes up,
strawberry blonde hair, pink Cardigan. Um, I knew my backbone shit and
in your bed, fall straight and tell me what's wrong. How old is she?
She's in high school. B diagnosis,
her scoliosis. That's don't, don't want to scare you.
Now I'm not trying to scare her.
Scoliosis of the spine is 100% of the time.
The mind like, okay, that's not even physical. That's a demon.
I'm standing next to Steve.
Do you believe it's going to be straightened right now? Can Be your hands full.
He spins her around. I break any generational curse off of my sister right now.
In Jesus' name. You'll spirit of scoliosis.
I break your power and then all of a sudden now in Jesus name won't be
straightened and Jesus,
she's kind of shoved her forward right now in Jesus name and Jesus.
Now try it now. Move around. Do what you're comfortable before.
Stand back and give yourself plenty of room
faith is what you're calling bill before.
I really don't want to say that she was healed or that she wasn't healed
painter cause she was just crying.
Isn't a hundred percent bad.
But I did meet a woman who something,
I think something did happen with the other woman that I met,
had a x-ray. There was nothing wrong with it from my phone sticks.
Now she comes up,
I'm older woman in her 50s or 60s and she just holds her hands out and I know I
cleaned some tents.
Try to grab something. You have carpal tunnel problems,
probably carpal tunnel. Explain what that is. I mean, as far as I know,
it's like an inflammation of the, of the ligaments and it's really,
really painful. It's a repetitive stress injury.
I want to show you something though. Sandra sand right here, sideways cover.
You could everybody see what he does is he basically tells her to to grip
together her little pen,
pinky and her phone and make a ring like an okay symbol.
Now I'm going to take my smallest finger, my pinky.
Then he sticks his finger in in the room.
Try to see if I can pull my pinky through your hands. He says,
I'm going to try to break it,
and he tried to stop me and I want you to fight me. Now I want to.
I want to see how much strength you have. After you're ready.
He just pops it right open. You got no strength. Throw it all day.
She can't hold her grip. That means she got trouble in her carpal tunnel,
which is right here. Give me those hands. Give me those hands.
She gives them her hand. He takes it in both of his carpal tunnel.
I command you in Jesus name for all swelling and inflammation rubbing right with
his thumbs.
I command all the ligaments and tendons that go back to the normally last.
Statistically that's supposed to be a narrowed command,
all pain to be gone over to this carpal tunnel region like coromandel healing
like one to this entire arm and his carpal tunnel and all strength that come
back there and Jesus now then do it again. He says, okay,
let's do the same demonstration right again.
He hasn't bring her pinky against your thumb like that. Make that grip.
I'm going to take my big finger and I'm going to fight you and when he puts his
finger in this and to watch what's going to happen in Paul, you're ready.
He doesn't break her grip and you can hear,
he just drags her right across the stage.
Okay.
This is the way it worked. It maybe did Lee's temporarily. Um,
she went back to her seat. They gave her a blanket. She was really trembling.
I went over to talk to her.
Can you describe what the experience was like for you?
I didn't feel anything at first.
But then when he did that thing,
Christian belief is that Christ died for our sins.
They actual phrases, which they always repeat is Jesus Christ. I'm healed.
By his stripes, we were healed by the stripes of Jesus. You were here, heal me.
When he died on the cross, what does that mean? It means that you were healed.
Meaning he died on the cross for our sins and also for our ailments.
So we've already been healed. We've already been healed.
We just have to access it and realize it by our connection and relationship to
God. Okay, so, so what happened to Linda afterwards?
The carpal tunnel came back almost immediately and um,
I met with her in a coffee shop.
But let's talk about, this is my belief from reading the word of God. The Devil,
Satan comes in, tries to talk you out of that. He, like he say,
you didn't really get healed. You know, like those things come into your mind.
And I believe that's just Satan.
So you have to have strong faith to stand against that
pain is Satan's way of testing her belief. I think that's what she thinks.
I talked to Satan and I tell him, yeah, like the pain is part of the test.
God says you're a liar and if the pain is there, she's not healed.
She's seeing this, this bigger struggle,
this bigger battle where pain is just one more kind of obstacles.
Not that there aren't times that I, I doubt I do. I thought I,
but I have to be pet and I have to say I'm sorry God.
I doubt it because I know you've healed me so many times and so many different
things so I know it's for real. It's,
you know, fake on my part cause I know that. I think that's a crucial point.
I mean if we think of it as a medical encounter,
it's about pain and the body.
But if we think of it as a spiritual encounter, the way she sees it,
it's really a battle against doubt.
Reporter Gregory Warner, thanks to him and to you for listening.
We've got to go now. Yup. Don't forget to visit our website, radio lab,
Duct Borg for more information on anything you've heard. Also,
you can sign up for our podcast at w n y C. Dot.
Org or on iTunes and always we'd love to hear what you think. Completely.
Radio lab at w n Y C. Dot. Org is the address. I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert [inaudible] signing off.